foreign
[Music]
North Korean government
and when you say you want to something
you know nasty well she is the one who
talked at all
[Music]
thank you
she as Kim jong-un's sister you know has
a special role to play Not only
institutionally within North Korea where
she does occupy some relatively high
official positions you know but also
unofficially as the spokesperson in part
for the for the Kim family regime her
message is consistent with what it is
that we think the Kim regime and North
Korea as a state think about the U.S
South Korea Alliance which ultimately
they would like to break apart
[Music]
thank you
foreign
came to prominent several years ago at
the time of all the summit diplomacy
between North Korea and the us and this
is a reminder that she is still a very
influential figure she has come out and
condemned a South Korea and the U.S
saying that the launch is a powerful and
overwhelming response to what she calls
threats from South Korea and the U.S
[Music]
thank you
as for who we could see is potentially a
successor to Kim Jong-un I think it's
far too early to say that it could be
you know his sister Kim Jong or whether
or not as we've seen recently some
discussion about whether or not it might
be Kim jong-un's daughter Julie or
someone else him is in principle far
away from being in a situation where a
successor would be necessary
[Music]